hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
High open show joining me on the show
today we have former federal agent he's
the co-host of one of the largest most
game-changing podcasts on the internet
and he's also the author of the brand
new book women deserve less Myron Gaines
welcome to the podcast how are you on
the show great to have you how you doing
today I'm good uh tired haven't slept
yet but hey it's okay yeah you're mine
yeah we make it happen I love that so
when I was thinking how am I going to
introduce Myron like how am I going to
introduce the fresh and fit podcast it
just hit me how influential and
successful the podcast has been thank
you because I I mean I'm sure you're
aware of this but everybody just just
has copied everything that you've done
you guys have set the gold standard now
um for the entire content creation for
the next couple years I mean the
whatever podcast has kind of copied you
pearly things is a little bit similar to
you you've really set the standard and
so I was like how am I going to
introduce this guy so my question too is
like did you expect to be so influential
and how does it feel
um you know it's it's interesting that
you mentioned that you know I always say
they can imitate but they can't
replicate um we just got the thing with
us is that it started from a very
genuine place where we just want to help
guys become better because we noticed
like all the [__] that's going on
with dating and how a lot of guys are
struggling and quite frankly it started
off
where I had to finish Channel first
fresh out a prank Channel and you know
we both basically met through another
YouTuber called solo tv84 and you know
he was doing his thing you know
womanizing I was doing my thing
womanizing and it's like when guys meet
each other and they're both like good
with girls it's like whoa you womanizer
I'm a womanizer do we just become best
friends and uh from there we kind of
built a bond because you know for to be
good and with lady with the ladies in
Miami especially it's very competitive
it's very difficult so um there's
certain unspoken rules and things that
you just kind of understand about the
game so we had a lot of I guess similar
strategies and everything else like that
so we realized like okay
um let's come together combine forces
and you know first and started with
Fitness and I noticed that guys want to
get in shape to get girls then I
realized like it wasn't just a fitness
issue it was guys stink they don't dress
well they don't have Prisma yeah I'm
actually shocked at how much girls
complain about hygiene with men like
it's actually one of the leading
complaints oh my God yeah I didn't
realize that until I actually started
talking to girls that that's a big
contributor to why so many guys fail but
just guys just don't have their life
together right to be able to attract
women so we're like all right we don't
just have to teach guys how to get in
shape we got to teach them like
everything get their money on point be
more charismatic be more Charming Etc so
the podcast really started off
with mail save improvement with the
purpose of you know becoming a better
man than women becoming a byproduct and
then we started bringing girls on the
show and you know having discussions and
debates and we started to realize like
wow a lot of modern day women are
delusional so yeah and then it's just
created viral content and yeah I wish I
could say scripted but no it's actually
all real and these girls are crazy you
know what's so funny
um I I don't understand how you're able
to find all of these crazy women
um I was actually going to ask you this
later on in the show but since we're
here now I'm gonna just jump straight
into it
your your perspective on on women is it
is it is it just the women on the show
like do you think all women are like
that out of Interest
no uh so what I've realized is that
because we bring because one of the
biggest criticisms we get is like oh you
just bring stupid Miami girls only and
the reality is that we bring girls in
from different walks of life right if
you if you actually watch the show at
the beginning of the show we used to ask
what's your name how old are you what's
your higher education level what do you
do for work what's your relationship
status Etc we brought girls in that have
phds Master degrees Etc
what I've realized is that regardless of
women's education level background
Etc
typically there's some commonalities and
what I've come to realize is that a lot
of girls have an over inflated sense of
self-worth right not all but I would say
a staggering majority and a lot of them
their wants are not necessarily
congruent with reality so in other words
they don't necessarily qualify for the
men that they think that they qualify
for every girl is pretty much chasing
the same archetype of guy six foot plus
100 000 plus a year Charming charismatic
in good shape six inch penis all this
crap and it's like a minority of men
actually meet these requirements and
what I've come to realize is thanks to
the globalized sexual marketplace with
Instagram dating apps Etc women have
access to these men right they're able
to get these guys for a night but are
they able to keep them long term and I
would argue most girls can't they can
get them for a night but they can't keep
them for a year so
um and I would say all that plays into I
guess what women think that they deserve
versus what they actually qualify for
and for all the people that get mad at
me oh well you just interviewed dumb
girls blah blah the only difference
between a girl that's educated a lot of
times that's a master's degree that has
money that's successful is that she's
even more stuck in her ways a lot of
times because she looks okay I'm
educated I make a lot of money I'm even
more entitled to this man because I
bring all this to the table but what
they don't realize is that your money
your status your title Etc it doesn't
really matter to a man and it matters
even less so for a guy who has his own
money in his own status it's really
frustrating at times but I look at it
like this okay I'm having these tough
discussions like this is a pain in the
ass but at least the audience can learn
that look it's literally futile to argue
with modern day women a lot of times
because no matter what you say no matter
how logically sound you are no matter
how much sense you make it doesn't
matter because women are ruled by their
emotions they don't feel like it's right
the number one thing that girls always
say we even made a shirt out of it but I
feel like yeah of course every time you
make a logical statement that makes
sense on how the world really works they
say well I feel like and I'm like listen
it doesn't matter how you feel what's
real how are you feeling what's real or
two different things but it's very
difficult for women to differentiate the
two yeah that's most not all right some
women are very logically sound but all
I've realized is that's a minority I'm
fortunately yeah no I think you're right
and I don't understand as well why um
women get so offended because I actually
think that like your content and a lot
of the red pill content is good for
women yeah like I think it's amazing for
women I think that I think Millennials
Millennial women got the worst of
feminism yes like their hit worse yeah
the women now in like their late teens
with your kind of content even though
they might be offended by it we'll just
have it at the back of their minds
playing as the years go by you know I
will say this one thing that I'm really
happy about because I look at the
um YouTube Studio a lot and I look at
like you know our viewership of females
and it's been going up we're almost at
10 so that's good yeah so not a
misogynistic yeah it's not and I always
say right I always make jokes I'm like
hahaha we're misogynistic whatever but
if you actually watch the podcast I
would say we're very realistic and the
thing is is that yeah life is sexist men
have a certain you know view of women
and the reality and women have a certain
view of certain things and I would say
the more women are able to look at
things objectively speaking and look at
the males lens the faster they'll be
able to find them in but the problem is
that a lot of women think that
the female way of thinking is the right
way to think which in some situations it
is with child rearing with being
nurturing to other people with being um
you know sympathetic Etc I don't think I
think women lack empathy but they're
able to be sympathetic but uh yeah which
is a big difference which I've I've come
to realize that over interviewing over
2000 women as women really lack empathy
but they have sympathy but not empathy
wait sorry why do you think that is the
reason why is because it's very
difficult for women to understand the
masculine experience and what I've
realized also is that
um women are able to sympathize right
like oh my God my life sucks blah blah
oh my God I'm so sorry for you but they
don't really give a [__] right versus I
argue that men have to be empathetic to
women because we can't attract and have
sex with women unless we're empathetic
think about it if you want to have sex
with a girl right you have to plan out
the date you have to make sure your
place is clean you got to make sure your
toilet doesn't look have [__] stains all
over the place right you got to make
sure the place smells good you gotta
have Music Ready you gotta have condoms
ready to go in case she doesn't like to
do the raw dog you have to have all
these things in place you have to be
cognizant of recovered levels you have
to make her feel comfortable you have to
escalate properly you have to touch her
in a certain way where she doesn't feel
awkward you can't just go in for the
kiss and just hunger down immediately
you have to escalate you know nice and
slowly so men have to be aware of all
these things so I would argue that
requires an intense amount of empathy
because you have to literally be able to
put yourself in the woman's shoes and be
able to escalate properly to turn her on
so men must have empathy to be
attractive to women however women don't
have to be empathetic to men to attract
men I always say women have the
privilege of just being kind of aloof
and Men come to them so they don't have
to understand men the men on the other
hand have to understand women to attract
them we can't get girls unless we
understand them
uh so so I want to ask you but I want to
save it for later sure but I I think we
could go wherever you need to go I'm
like oh okay
well I I want to ask you how a woman
should then you know retain a man
because she will get to I'm not I just
don't ask you just now but I will get to
that um because you know you're saying
women can just be aloof and be quite
passive yeah but I'm not sure if that's
100 right but we can get to that
um out of curiosity the podcast and
everything that you have so I still kind
of want to understand how it came about
is an incredible setup like you have
dozens of cameras you've got security
you've got so many different angles like
everything is is amazing so if you don't
mind me asking sure how did you make
your money before that because
that takes a lot of money to start
investing and doing all of this was it
real estate was it crypto I don't know
was it being a federal agent like how
did you actually no I'm very transparent
about my finances so I don't have a
problem talking about that openly and
this is our public record too so when
you're searching the internet every
little thing you do is being recorded
and tracked by your internet
search engines
not only is this an invasion of your
privacy but they are then selling your
data and monetizing you this is why you
need a virtual private Network or a VPN
for short a VPN hides your IP address
and safeguards your internet connection
through an encrypted tunnel this way it
Shields your Digital Life from the eyes
of those looking to exploit your private
information private internet access VPN
gives you more privacy features than any
other software including protection
against malware and trackers when you
subscribe to private internet access VPN
you can have it on an unlimited number
of devices from your iPhone to your
computer tablet and more not only does
this protect your privacy but it also
improves your entire digital experience
for example watching Netflix without
private internet access is like getting
dozens of gifts for your birthday but
you can only open one that's because
Netflix has a huge catalog of content
but you can only watch a fraction of
that based on your location so with this
VPN you can can change your IP address
and now you have access to everything
Netflix and the entire internet has to
offer also you can pay for the
subscription using cryptocurrency
private internet access VPN is
completely open source which shows your
data isn't being logged so start
protecting yourself with private
internet access VPN and use my special
link in the description below when I
worked for the government I was a
special agent with Homeland screen
investigations basically I did like
Mexican cartel investigations everything
from terrorism human smuggling human
trafficking drugs gun trafficking
everything right and I was on the
Southwest border then I moved to Miami
so when I was here in Miami station
I was in Asia I was making about 120
hundred thirty thousand dollars per year
I'm a minimalist I wear the same clothes
all the time so I pretty much was able
to save a good amount of that money and
what happened is I started my Fitness
business when I started that Fitness
business I was able I was making around
same amount about 120 to 130 140k per
year right so I pretty much doubled my
income I earned about 300K that year
this is
2019. wow yeah so so with that money
that I had saved from the Fitness
business I put a good amount of it away
right and um so inevitably right we
start to go viral and they bring me in
you know hey you know Myron you know you
know you can't be talking like this on
on the internet like bro you're a
federal agent like at the time I had one
of the biggest National Security cases
for Homeland in in the country okay
okay I won't say two I can't say too
much about it
it was it was it was a natural security
case concerning I'm just going to say
the United States Miami Turks and Caicos
and um Canada sounds like Sri Lankans
sounds like drugs yeah it was it was no
no drugs this case actually this one a
little bit of drugs but it was a whole
other thing and then I had another case
also which was a organized crime case
which was a drug case that was a drug
investigation but I had two of the
biggest cases in my in my group and one
of the biggest cases in the country at
the time right and actually it's funny
because when I got doxed that's the case
that they exposed that's why I couldn't
talk about it because it's a public
record this Sri Lankan case but anyway
um so I had this case uh and I was
making the money and everything else
like that I was doing I had my Fitness
business I was on YouTube at this point
as well and I was uh doing this case so
they bring me in I'll never forget it
was November of 2020. hey you know
you're saying the [__] on the internet
what's going on I think I only had like
10 000 subscribers on YouTube at the
time so they kind of put me in a rocket
or hard place so it was like yo like you
got to cut the YouTube for a few months
at this point we're starting to build
momentum right like we had just got the
studio I had just invested about forty
fifty thousand dollars into the studio I
got the new spot right and we had the
panels up and the cameras and all this
other stuff so they told me this we had
film like two episodes so at this point
we had employees also and all this other
stuff because things were like you know
going up so like damn what am I gonna do
I went back and forth trying to come to
the middle ground with the agency and
they're like nah man like you got to get
a get off social media so I had to make
a decision and I resigned I'll never
forget I resigned December 5th 2020 and
it hurt man I turned in my badge I
turned in my credentials I turned in my
vest I turned in all my equipment my M4
all that crap man and it sucked so um
because I really did love that job it
made me a man like um you know I make
fun of a lot of YouTubers like they
don't have personal experience they
haven't been through adversity whatever
like at 24 years old I was literally
putting guns to cartel dudes faces right
I was arresting people I was writing
reports I was testifying like like it
was a really hard job I was up late at
night like I sacrificed my 20s on the
Southwest border in Texas wasn't
drinking wasn't partying out in the
middle of [__] nowhere in the desert
and stuff like that but I really that
job made me a man so I I have a very
strong tide away and I miss it that's
why I still do my feta Channel now where
I cover like True Crime and stuff but um
so anyway I had that money saved up had
the studio I had to walk away from the
agency so at that point it was like do
or die right thankfully I had saved the
money and what I did was also I cleaned
out my uh tsp or Thrift Savings Plan for
the government and I bought my first
real estate property right I bought it
pretty much cash
um so I bought my first real estate
property we started generating money
from YouTube and we had some courses out
Etc
um so we were making money at that point
and we had a patreon whatever so and
that was a minimalist so it was we and I
had already paid for everything pretty
much like I used a credit card but I had
the money cash so we were good at that
point and you know we made it work and
uh that's kind of how we got it started
and then as we started scaling up Etc
bought more equipment let's get invested
back into business ended up working out
and then all the money I made because
like my number one thing was like once I
got out the government I was like okay I
need to replace this 120k per year job
through real estate I need to make about
10K per month to be able to hit that so
I just bought real estate aggressively
that first year I bought seven
properties in one year then the
following year I bought another five and
I was able to like double triple that
um so I'm good now around if I get
canceled like half you guys I'm good you
know yeah but uh but that was my number
one goal was to replace that government
income passively with real estate
um I own 12 properties now
and yeah I mean invest in crypto as well
uh you know got some ethereum Bitcoin
I'm not a super pro like you but I'm
super basic and you know some precious
metals luxury watches right that hold
value nothing jeweled out or anything
like that obviously plain Jane but
that's kind of how it got started I
appreciate you sharing that because
people always wondering you know how do
I start I mean even on the way here we
took an Uber and the Uber driver was
asking they know you by the way oh nice
yeah yeah and me and they like they
loved everyone and and they're like oh
like how do you start how do you start
and I'm like well watch the show I'm
gonna ask Myron yeah so yeah so I would
say the path is I had a job right so I
had a because everyone says I want to be
an entrepreneur I want to be an
entrepreneur and I really want guys to
like understand that you know you know
there's this laptop lifestyle and
internet like yeah dude you could be an
entrepreneur digital nomad but like
there's nothing wrong with working a job
a hiring job right six figures whatever
it may be taking that money saving it
and investing it into assets that pay
you back like the goal isn't necessarily
to be an entrepreneur the goal is to be
financially free you can get there
through being an entrepreneur or having
an earned income job nothing wrong with
that
um the thing is you might be do it a
little bit slower right working for
someone else but you can still become
financially free if you invest in the
right assets my choice is always real
estate because you get the tax benefits
you get the depreciation you get the
cost segregation you get the cash flow
you get the appreciation it's a w all
around right and in the United States
right it's probably one of the best ways
to mitigate your tax liability
yeah so that's that's why I tell people
all the time man like it's not about
being an entrepreneur it's about getting
out the rat race and becoming
financially free you can do it with a
hiring job a high income skill you could
be a doctor lawyer invest in real estate
you know invest in crypto whatever it
may be get something to pay you back a
dividend get that passive income and get
the hell out and then once you've done
all of that you've got to find a nice
woman so yes let's let's let's get let's
get to the Crux of this now so sure you
talk a lot about this so many problems
with women we've kind of touched on it
already
um but I'm curious what would you say
some of the main issues are with modern
Western women right now
wow okay so just don't don't hold back
you won't offend me it's fine no it's
fine it's fine I I wouldn't say you
really fit into these uh things because
one of the ones I'm going to say the the
foundation I would say the root problem
is a lack of critical thinking skills
okay and what I mean by this is they
tend to go off of their feelings and not
necessarily it's off how they feel
versus what's real right so
even in the face of logic and numbers
it's about oh well I'm gonna manifest it
or I I hope it's gonna happen I can't
tell you how many times we have a
delusion calculator on our show right
and we'll ask a girl okay describe your
dream man we'll put his height in six
foot three never fails hundred thousand
dollars per year it's like the magic
height yeah pretty much right or over
six feet nine out of ten times you know
black or white or whatever it may be or
sometimes they'll put all race do you
want to be educated yeah like college
degree would be nice blah blah and then
we you know and here's the thing our
calculator is very accurate it comes
from the National Health survey and from
the U.S Census Bureau so it's the most
accurate assessment of men in the United
States and it comes out to like one
percent and it literally in a sense and
it gets like a Cat-Back score it'll be
like five out of five so it'll get five
out of five cat bags right and and the
girl will see like it's less than one
percent of men and I'll be like okay the
chance of you finding this guy are
literally like no nowhere to be found
and they'll still say I'm gonna manifest
it instead of dropping their standards
and like thinking like damn do I qualify
for this guy I'm 32 years old I got a
master's degree like is this guy gonna
back right I make a hundred thousand
plus a year but I'm not that hot I'm a
little overweight do I qualify for this
guy instead of having critical thinking
skills and saying I should probably
lower my standard so I can find a man
that I want be able to have children
have a family because that's going to
give me real satisfaction they say no
I'm going to manifest it he's out there
somewhere and the worst part the girls
at the table help them indulge in the
delusion yeah girl you go you're gonna
fight them and I literally just let them
go and I look say audience y'all see
this this is why women perpetually stay
single because they give each other
terrible advice they coach each other
and they don't say anything like to tell
them the truth like girl you might want
to lower your standards hell no they
never tell each other the truth do you
think
um there are women that do deserve these
kinds of men like do you think if a
woman wants this she's actually not
delusional is there like look do you
what do you have to be to be delusional
is it like old and fat and Masters
Degree I would say no it's it's just
it's just an unawareness of where they
qualify right so it's it's thinking I'm
successful so I deserve a successful man
and unfortunately the metrics to get
that man aren't your success as a woman
I would say another big thing that is
unspoken and people get mad at me for
saying this is if a woman wants a guy
that's higher status higher earning Etc
you got to be prepared to share him
which means he's gonna [__] other
[__] bro it doesn't matter what you
say every higher status guy typically
has one or two or three girls maybe he
has main chicken he has a mistress maybe
he has two or three wives but they
always or they mess around with escorts
they always have other women that's like
the biggest thing that girls can't get
over but that comes back to that
delusion you're telling me you're an
average looking girl and you think you
deserve a top shelf guy and he's going
to be monogamous to you like what that's
ridiculous guys don't go ahead and
conquer the world and make all this
money and get in shape and [__] to [__]
one [__] that's ridiculous that's
literally ridiculous and I tell girls
all the time I'm never gonna be
monogamous I didn't like become a
multi-mooner one [__] that's stupid
that's why I think a man of God is is a
good thing you know a good Christian man
a good Christian he's got one [__]
too is he gonna do it I don't think
you're gonna go Christian man he would
have to be super super aligned with
religion and the thing is is that
honestly that guy he's gonna go find a
girl in the church he's gonna go find a
girl that's like a virgin or some [__]
he's gonna go like out of his way to
find like a a girl that's like super
religious like him you know so what
other issues are there with uh modern
women so we're delusional yeah we lead
with our emotions yeah so lack of
critical thinking skills right
fairly delusional about where they stand
in the pecking order okay
um chasing the wrong things right so
pursuing a career and income and
thinking that's going to make them more
attractive to the man that they want I
can't tell you how many times we ask a
girl what do you bring to the table to a
man that's successful and they say my
money my status he does oh women say it
all the time all the time dude because
think about it if they go to school and
they pursue a master's degree or a
bachelor's degree or they work really
hard to get their job they should be
proud of it right I get it
um but we masculinize women and we tell
them go ahead and Chase a career make
money and that's going to make you more
attractive to a man and the reality is
men really don't give a [__] but girls
don't know this they think that men care
because the other thing too is that
women think another big mistake that
modern day women have they think
attraction is symmetrical but the
reality is what does that mean so it's
the same thing between men and women but
the reality is that it's asymmetrical so
the things that a man are attracted to
versus the things that our women are
attracted to are completely different
what I mean by this is women typically
look for survival value height strength
income competence confidence ambition
they look for skill sets that will allow
the man to provision for her long term
and her children men on the other hand
look for what I call replication value
can you give me hot ass kids are you hot
are you fertile are you young is your
hair long do you have nice teeth all
these things like men look for
replication value women look for
survival value so but women on the other
hand think that men look for survival
value which is absolutely ludicrous
because when a man comes into a
relationship with a woman most guys at
least the guys that women want aren't
looking like oh this chick's totally
going to support me like no very
masculine men will not accept the dollar
from a woman like if I'm out with a girl
I will never let her pay because that's
just like my thing I'm not what the hell
no you're not going to pay I'm the one
running this and the other thing too why
tell guys why you got to pay for dates
and Lead dates Etc it's because you
control the frame which is inherently
attractive this is so funny to me
because um and I'll try to like keep
this uh oh I get so personal but I know
I I know a lot of different people in on
in the online space and I know how they
how they interact personally
in the real world once they've taken off
their online mask and a lot of these men
who who are like yeah you've got to hold
frame and I'm the man and all that like
that's playing bills with women and [__]
yeah I know it's really funny to me
they're sling bills unacceptable and
yeah these are men that people know and
I'm here like me and y4 we're gonna go
out of this I'm not going to let her pay
why four yeah she's off camera but yeah
what
what has a not like a career but you
know she has a job obviously you know so
here's something she has money obviously
not as much as you but she has money
um so should should you should you still
be paying so here's my thing with women
and jobs and everything I'm not
anti-women working or anti-women making
money what my thing is I always say this
right and it's kind of funny because
women get mad at me when I say this
right I think for a woman working is
elective if you want to go out and
pursue a career and make money cool but
I will cover all the main bills Etc
you're my girl I'm gonna provide and
take care of you because I think the man
should be the breadwinner and if woman
does want to work it needs to be
elective now on the other side right
girls get mad at me when I say this I
think it's elective for a girl to come
who cares about a girl's coming the
guy's got to come yeah see I knew
someone's gonna get mad at that yeah so
I think it's so this is what it what
tickets I think for a man working well
excuse me for a woman working as
elective for a man making his girl come
as elective because a woman's job is to
satisfy her man sexually a man's
opposite provide a protect for his woman
because to be honest with you men have
to bring way more to the table than
women do in general so you want me to
protect you provide for you be a leader
make more money than you you know be
more competent confident than you and
make you come what the hell it's not a
fair trade like that's [__] so I'm
not gonna get into too much detail about
this because that would be slightly
unladylike but what I will say what I
will say is
um so I think working outside of the
working I think working is elective
um and and I agree um I think even if
she makes a little bit of money it's
still all on him but then if she decides
to work she's still better be bringing
what she needs to bring to the table
right the femininity the peace the home
the nurture yeah she decides to work
yeah once her work like gets into you
know messing with her head and hurting
the quality of the relationship that's
when you got to cut those hours back Etc
um but you know I think she should be I
think women should have the comfort and
secure and I think every woman yearns
for this but they can't find it of being
able to go to work or do whatever they
do and be able to tell their boss at any
point in time [__] you I don't need this
job I think every woman wants to be able
to tell their boss that should they need
to work if you want but if your boss
talks to you crazy you can always say
[__] you I don't need this job my man
takes care of me [__] I'll just
get an allowance or some [__] I don't
know but girls want that deep down yeah
no I agree with you um in terms of like
the other the stuff
you know I I don't know like that's for
every couple to decide oh the uh the
coming thing oh yeah you know I'm just
being funny yeah that's very comfortable
but what I will say is if you can't
satisfy her in the bedroom she's she may
look elsewhere so I'll leave that to you
Myron you know that's why I said it's
electric I'll leave that to you one out
of every two sessions maybe well now
what 50 of the time you
remember all these other things she
should be happy I'm sure that will
satisfy her too anyway
um so and most girls real quick get off
on their guy getting off most women get
not most but a large one in the room
just like um
I feel like it was Wi-Fi before that
said that maybe her I wasn't with my
brother okay oh that was her too okay
um but a lot a large amount of women do
get off on their guy getting off you
know what I mean because for women they
understand that their value a lot of
times comes from
um their sexuality and their beauty and
uh being able to satisfy a man sexually
is a big thing for a woman because let's
be honest here the main reason why guys
deal with women is for their sexuality
that's the main reason if girls don't
have vaginas guys want to talk to them
yeah do you know what I agree we're
we're annoying we're we're a lot there's
a reason why they call homosexual guys
gay because gay means hit Mary and happy
to deal with each other yeah so what
would you say some of the biggest
differences are between
um Western women and Eastern women and
like because I know that's something you
talk a lot about
um yeah so I spent a good amount of time
in uh in Dubai United Arab Emirates and
they're becoming westernized don't don't
make no mistake about it like they're
becoming super westernized right the
women aren't covering their hair
superheron which I'm not the best Muslim
either so I'm being I'm a little bit of
a hypocrite too but
um when I spent
I noticed this when I was in Romania as
well
um the women are just more feminine
they're more ladylike in general um here
in America like the women are super
masculine they'll talk to you like
they're a guy a lot more swearing a lot
louder a lot more crass
um you know um when you bring in a like
one thing I noticed about like with like
foreign girls
is um especially like we're Romanian
women if I bring them like around my
friends or whatever they're quiet they
don't like talk you know what I mean
like it's like okay the men are talking
I'm just gonna be quiet which I think is
like a very it's kind of like an
understated thing that's attractive it's
like you're just there you don't speak
unless you're spoken to you don't
embarrass your guy you make him look
good if it's his house or whatever you
ask the guys if they want anything to
drink you bring them Refreshments like
that's how I was raised like I come from
a two brand also like my mom anytime my
dad's friends came in my mom always went
to the you know kitchen immediately made
food gave them Refreshments like my dad
didn't have to say anything like she
just knew what time it was she just made
him look good every single time even
when they came every day she just made
it happen so I think that's something
that's also lost in uh Western women
like catering to their man and his
friends and always making him look good
and not embarrassing him but America
women a lot of times feel okay with
talking you crazy in front of your
friends talking back to you
disrespecting you challenging your
Authority in front of your friends like
these are all things that are super
unattractive oh I'm gonna be witty and
uh rambunctious and like uh tease my guy
and uh challenge him what the [__] is
that [__] nobody wants that I don't
know what clown is telling girls like
yeah Challenger man shut up like the
world already challenges men like men
don't want to be challenged by that girl
shut up make a sandwich suck my dick a
little bit I'll be good
um so it's funny that you say that
because I I think that um those men are
more masculine too
so I think Eastern European men yes are
more masculine you know the Arab men in
the Middle East yeah they're more
masculine whether you know Israeli men
they're more masculine even though than
boys even though yeah people yeah them
boys we don't really anyway
um but so that's interesting why do you
think that is like that is the place to
go to find a husband or a wife the other
side well typically the poorer the
country and I grew with Andrew on this
we've talked we've talked about this
when I was in Romania hanging out with
them
that typically the poorer country is the
more people revert to their natural
gender roles right yeah so you know you
look at you know a Colombia Thailand uh
you know Philippines
um
Brazil South America all the you know
Eastern Europe Ukraine right Ukraine
used to be a huge place where guys would
go to get girls uh Romania all these
places right Russia like people tend to
you know align more with their natural
gender roles because that's their
natural state and it allows them to go
ahead and fend off the elements right
better when they're in their natural
generals right like women understand
that I am physically inferior to a man
so I should have a man do physical labor
Etc and go out and create excess
resources for me and the children I'm
gonna stay back and take care of the
children and nurture them Etc that's how
things worked for centuries right that's
how the world became the world that it
is now where we are able to have the I
call the privilege of being in a first
world Cloud world where you know the
gender roles are mixed and we don't know
what the genders are and we don't know
what a man is or a woman is we can't
even Define what a woman is now anymore
so it's clown World stuff so but it's
because of men and women being in their
traditional generals for so long that
we've been having to have we've been
able to have the privilege of people
being able to not be able to distinguish
genders anymore that's how good we have
it yeah it's like I always say work
culture is born out of boredom and
entitlement yes so like things are so
easy yes that we can just pretend
there's you know a virus going around
yes let a war happen and watch everyone
yeah well let's see all these crazy
feminists let's see if they enroll in
the draft let's see if they can go in
the military yeah that's how you get a
woman in the kitchen you gotta put that
apron on real quick and go back to
making [__] sandwiches so it's like
yeah you know anytime there's conflict
like here's the other thing too evil
with the craziest feminist you know I've
asked this before on the show oh a woman
can do anything a man can do okay not
really like if you're calling 9-1-1 you
don't want you know two lesbians with
Butch haircuts what's the problem here
no you want two dudes toxically
masculine beards chest hair someone like
you coming in
yeah you want that guy to come in and
save you don't want like two lesbians
that are five foot three out of shape
and put you you don't want them coming
in to save the day they're not gonna
save the day they can't do it if there's
a dude there I've seen literally I've
seen police videos right and this coming
from a guy in law enforcement I've seen
videos where I see two two female
officers they can't even subdue one
teenage guy them up and runs away it's
like bro what what's going on here man
yeah what blows my mind is the fact that
like that is just such an obvious
reality that you're just not allowed to
talk about you're not allowed to say
um and speaking of Andrew his interview
uh Piers Morgan was so funny to me
because he's like trying to convince
peers of these realities yeah and I'm
like Pierce like bro like what are you
what are you talking about this is just
the UK took Ella on that one
I think you had to do that to be a
contrarian because I think deep down
Pierce Morgan understands that world
culture is [__] but he is employed
by a big Media Company Etc they just
fired Tucker Carlson for being you know
pretty basic being too cool yeah
mainstream media is is going downhill
man that was the last like you know
Bastion right there for mainstream media
the fact that they got rid of Tucker
Carlson it's it's all around from here
yeah no I totally agree with you
um and I think now would be a great time
to bring up your book sure why women
deserve less so Myron why why do I as a
woman deserve less what did I do so I'm
a bad person so the the thing is the
book is about about not being a simp
right so men in today's day and age
right are kind of conditioned by old
1950 standards of being a gentleman and
being chivalrous and you know doing all
these things and what I'm saying is that
you got to change the game for men right
because you're basically what I say now
with dating is if you go ahead and
you're chivalrous and you're a gentleman
you're a nice guy that's basically
bringing a butter knife to like a
bazooka fight because dating has evolved
so much in the past
60 70 years thanks to the Advent of
social media dating apps Etc women have
more options than ever before so what
that's done is that's directly
influenced how women perceive men and in
general right I have a chapter on it
that's kind of dark where I talk about
most women simply don't like most men so
you need to get into that top percentage
of men where women actually want to deal
with you most women look at men as kind
of like a means to an end to get to
where they want whether it's a free
dinner a sugar daddy maybe a trip here
or there but they don't actually like
you and I want guys to get in a position
where women actually like you and want
to be around you want to hang out with
you want to spend time with you because
that's when you get the best treatment
out of women is when they actually love
admire and respect you not whereas
you're a trick or doing this other stuff
and you know women are just tolerating
you which was where most guys stand
women are simply just tolerating them I
find that really sad like for me
personally
um like I won't marry anyone unless I
think the world of him like I really
like I want to admire someone and be
like wow like you are like you know I
don't want to put up with someone that's
horrible yeah and a lot of women do and
I and I can understand that because I've
seen how some of my girlfriends have
just stayed in relationships and I'm
like but you know he's kind of like this
and they're you know they're they're
happy with it whereas I'm just this is
my theory I call it the placeholder
boyfriend right so a lot of women what
they do is for fear of being alone what
they'll do is they'll get a guy that's
just good enough man maybe you know he
makes just enough money he's cute just
enough he like helps them not feel alone
but she still has her Instagram open
she's still going out with her
girlfriend she's still sourcing for a
better man maybe she's going to a party
here or there maybe she gets invited out
and goes and gets flown out somewhere
like a lot of girls are in a position
where they're with a guy that's just
good enough but he doesn't meet all the
requirements but he's good enough to be
a placeholder boyfriend so she doesn't
feel alone she have to go to sleep at
night all the time just have to sleep
with her you know Ben and Jerry's ice
cream by herself so what I want guys to
do also is I tell guys if you're not the
one then there is none you need to be
the number one option where literally
not only are you the one number one
option but all other men are virtually
invisible to her and you can only
command that if you're a top tier guy
and she feels like she has the best that
she can get because when a woman feels
that she has the best she can get all
other men are virtually visible to her
hypergamy which is the practice of
dating up for a woman is based in doubt
so a woman becomes more hypergamous
wanting to get a better man when she
doesn't know where her man stands so I
don't want guys to be a placeholder
boyfriend if you're just being tolerated
or you're just good enough and she's
still going on a girls nights out she's
still hanging out with her guy friends
or whatever she does respect you she
doesn't like you that much in just a
matter of time until you get cut and a
better guy comes in and takes your place
I'm interested because you said that the
night you know you don't want men to be
doing the 1950s chivalrous thing yeah
unfortunately so but but then but then
um I think correct me if I'm wrong I
think a woman who has raised right and
like you know respects herself and has
good values and she's like that won't
want to be um like messed around and she
can she's smart enough to know when
she's been taken seriously and when he's
just messing around so how there has to
be some kind of balance like you've got
to be nice to like a woman like you
you've got to be nice to her and it's
not just a fantastic point it's not just
about paying for her and covering the
food like maybe her dad can do that
maybe her brother can do that maybe she
can do that yeah but it you know it's
about like what what kindness and love
do you give her so here's the balance so
what I say is women have to earn
chivalry in 2023 and Beyond nowadays
right like I always say chivalry is dead
and women killed it right and the thing
is is that nowadays what guys have to do
is you have to make a woman earn you
being a gentleman right obviously on a
first date right you pay for the date
whatever that's just a given right basic
stuff like that but you shouldn't even
be going out on the first date with her
unless she's compliant she's submissive
she's you're she's giving you some
semblance of respect right if you you
know say hey we're going to meet here at
this time blah blah she doesn't try to
switch it up and say let's go to Poppy
steak or some other [__] like that
right and try to dictate the frame or
trying to go to an expensive place
because she doesn't like you that much
so I say you need to show that chivalry
and that respect
um if the girl earns it the days of you
just giving it away those days are gone
because the problem is that when you're
a nice little girl up front and you're
chivalrous up front she's going to take
that as weakness and she's going to use
it to finesse you a lot of the time is
every woman like that no but I teach
guys this is how you gotta move unless
the woman proves otherwise it's on her
to prove otherwise So when you say the
examples that you gave of not earning it
yeah sounded like pretty just like uh no
like normal behavior like like don't you
know if he like just fall into his frame
if you set a date just say yes if he's
done that like what you said to me
sounded kind of odd so which part
say you set a date with you and a woman
can you give me an example of how she
then doesn't earn the chivalry like what
is she doing she's saying actually I
don't want to go there I want to go here
like if you suggest that you see say you
suggest like Mila which is a lovely
restaurant in Miami and she's like
actually I'd rather go to Pappy steak is
that her not earning it yeah so that's a
red flag right but women are doing that
like that absolutely see this is what
this is where like my my thing with like
the content I don't understand because I
don't know a woman
like if a man
's new to Mila I'll be like oh my God
thank you you know I'm so excited yeah
like great I'm not like can we go to
Pappy's and I don't blame you for not
knowing because you're a female so you
don't deal with [__] from other
females unfortunately for you but yeah
so
um what happens is right when a woman
doesn't like you like that right a
Telltale sign is she'll try to switch
the data up on you maybe she'll try to
get a more extravagant experience
because she doesn't like you that much
so what she's trying to do is she's
trying to basically extract the most
value from the interaction that she can
from you right because she doesn't like
you that much typically when a girl
likes you uh she'll be okay with
whatever it is because she just wants to
spend time with you but if she doesn't
like you that much she's gonna try to
switch the date up on you she's going to
try to do something else that benefits
her more than you these are all red
flags that men need to look for so when
I say that women need to earn chivalry
uh her not falling into your frame is an
example or a red flag where you need to
kind of come in and some girls do that
just to test you right I've had girls
before where they'll try that abortion
I'm like no that's not how we're gonna
do these things and sometimes they'll
get in line just off of that right
because they're like whoa what's the
first time a guy's told me no this is
hot right for most guys a lot of times
are like oh you want to go there sure
let's go I'll bring you some flowers too
that's what I don't want guys doing yeah
and what other ways um does a woman not
earn the chivalry like what else can she
do so he doesn't
so he pulls back and doesn't do that so
from the female perspective for the male
perspective because when I give advice
so here's the thing when I give advice
to women versus men you always have to
give one gender an advantage when you
give dispense advice to them that puts
the other one at a disadvantage that's
dating right within dating one party
always has to care more than the other
the party that cares less has a leverage
now my argument is that the man needs to
have the leverage at all times in a
relationship for it to work because when
the man has a leverage and the woman
feels like she has the best man that she
can get she's chasing his validation all
men are available to her it keeps her
happy satisfies the hypergamy men on the
other hand if we have the leverage yeah
we might go [__] another [__] or
whatever but your girl is your girl like
you're not gonna care about other women
the same as like your main chick or main
chicks so when a man has a leverage it
just works better for everybody
everybody's satisfied that's so funny it
can satisfy the
yes you had to satisfy the hypergamy
that that's the biggest thing where guys
mess up I know because women are always
looking for the best deal yeah so you
had to become that best deal that's why
I tell guys yo the days of being an
average guy making 50k per year it's
done it's [__] done you need to make
six figures you need to have money saved
you need to have um your [__] together
you got to be in shape in the gym it's
unacceptable to be fat that's why I tell
guys if you're fat you're a [__]
loser I don't have no sympathy for fat
people whatsoever if you're a fat man if
you're a fat chick you can still get a
date you're a fat dude bro you better be
a multi-multi-millionaire it's in the
gym but being an average guy nowadays
you're you're done bro like you
literally have to satisfy female
hypergamy you can only do that by having
everything in check being charismatic
being Charming being uh in shape getting
your money on point uh being dominant
being confident you need all these
things in place to be able to get a girl
in line even average women are not going
to accept a guy that's above average
anymore
and get them to submit like they'll
tolerate you right like you'll get a
date you'll get girls to date you you'll
get you'll be able to keep a girl from
whatever but I want you to be in a
position where she's like holy [__] yeah
I have the fear of God that if this guy
leaves me my life is gonna suck that's
what I want where where I want guys to
be where they have the woman where she
is infatuated with him that's the only
way you get the best out of women they
have to care about you and respect you
and love you more than you love them no
I think I think that's pretty right I
don't disagree and it sucks because
that's how I wish it could be like
chivalry where I could show up on her
first day with flowers and give you the
world baby and oh my God let me put my
jacket on there yeah [__] puddle and
all this [__] I wish it could be like
that but unfortunately women respond
horribly to nice guys and we have all
the evidence to prove it you look at
guys nowadays how many dudes are in the
friend zone
a million Right girls are out here going
on dates I think there was a study done
one in three it's a 50 of women go on
dates for free dinners craziness okay so
that bit's really weird to me because
I'm hearing and by the way this just
isn't a thing in England and I don't
care what anyone says England is just
way more low-key than it is in America
I'm hearing like women are getting flown
out here and they're flown out there so
I've never done that none of my
girlfriends from home have ever done
that it's all very uh bizarre to me um
the reason it's bizarre to me because
it's like why would you want to fly
somewhere and like put up with someone
like I I wouldn't want to be in a
foreign country with someone that I
don't know that well like I don't feel
safe I don't I don't like that like you
know maybe he expects sex from you like
it's all just too much when you just
rather stay home with your parents at
this point the reason why a big reason
why and I'll tell you is because a lot
of women value experiences over dignity
and what I mean by that is I can't tell
you how many attractive girls I know
that have been to on private jets and
Lamborghinis and Ferraris in Tulum and
you know Dubai Etc going getting these
crazy extravagant experiences they want
to put it up on their Instagram because
girls love to flex against each other
like my lifestyle [__] look at this
blah blah so girls will sit there and
sell their soul for it I can't tell you
how many girls I mean well wife number
four knows this we had a girl on the
show right yesterday literally they said
I used to be a nurse I was a higher
earner making 100K plus per year but she
said [__] it I prefer to go on only fans
make more money so I can live a certain
lifestyle like living a certain
lifestyle and acquiring experiences and
material things means a lot to women
like it really means a lot that's why if
you look at girls on
Instagram whatever it's all just the big
Flex on other girls look at where I'm at
look at this selfie look at me in this
Ferrari look at this extravagant
lifestyle that I live but what girls
don't realize another big thing that
modern day women don't realize is
anytime you take a picture in a Ferrari
on a private jet in foreign locations
whatever like do stink [__] whoa 304 but
girls think that that [__] is cool but
they they do it to flex on other women
it's so weird it's so strange to me so
what's your ideal woman
silent make sandwiches sex no I'm just
kidding uh give us a little bit more
than that no no I'm just kidding I'm
very simple when it comes to girls like
if she's respectful not a hoe doesn't
embarrass me
um quiet if I need her to do things for
me respects me Etc that's gonna be good
man accentuates my life if I need
something done or whatever hey like
girls typically that I've had
uh stick with by my side most of the
time it's like this doesn't sound evil
when I say this but you need a girl to
kind of do things for you yes to really
fall in love with you like women fall in
love through giving acts of servitude to
a man that they admire and respect so
you have to put a girl to work right a
lot of guys like kind of just put a girl
like they get a girl and they don't like
have her do nothing and she don't
respect them because he's not doing [__]
blah blah you have to put a girl to work
because a girl's not going to grow to
love you until she invests in you and
the thing where guys make us big mistake
is they invest everything in the
relationship and the girl doesn't do
[__] right but the girl you got to get
her to invest in you I'd argue you need
to get the girl to invest in you more
than you invest in her that's how she
gets really connected and women need
that Bond they need that emotional
connection and them doing acts of
servitude helps with that
what do you prefer a woman who um
is trainable or a woman who is already
red pilled understands that mold or is
there no difference you're happy with
both like do you can you be bothered to
train a woman
uh I think I think that's an important
component A girl's gotta be here's the
thing I'll take a dumb girl all day if
she's inquisitive impressionable and
trainable because I can make her smart
smarter right my leader I have you know
have the confidence to have the
competence to make her a better woman
and I think most girls that end up being
like the best girlfriends their
boyfriend has to train him to a degree
hey that's what I need you to do for me
because the man is a leader a component
of leadership is being able to instruct
people and lead them to success and to
get your girl to be the best girlfriend
that she could be you have to lead her
you know but the problem is that a lot
of guys don't have leadership skills
they ask to grow what do you want to do
oh my God all the stupidity like you
know I always say it like people oh you
sex is blue misogynistic but I'm
realistic most women don't even know
what the [__] they want to eat for lunch
how the hell do you expect her to guide
you in life like no like women are not
born leaders there's a reason why since
the beginning of time men have led
societies and patriarchy stand the test
of time and matriarchies die off because
women aren't born leaders they're too
emotional they're not deductible problem
solvers they don't use rationale they
use feelings and that's a problem when
you use feelings that's a bad thing if
you look at men that use feelings what
are they School shooters criminals
rapists murderers Etc pedophiles because
they're off going off of emotion they're
not able to control themselves when men
aren't able to control their emotions
really bad things happen because men are
capable of violence and savagery but
women aren't able to control their
emotions it's like it's kind of natural
for them so
that's why men need to be in leadership
roles because women aren't natural
leaders are there women that can lead
right there's always exception to the
rules there's always going to be
fantastic women that could be lead and
be boss and all this other stuff but on
the balance of probabilities most can't
mm-hmm I ask because
um so when I was about 1920 yeah I would
I would say I was like a feminist but I
was definitely you were one of those no
no it wasn't crazy about this but but I
was definitely
um you know I thought that I was proud
you know to make my own money and and
you know I I like
um intellectual things like I like
politics and crypto and whatever and so
I'm like yeah that'll be fun to work in
that area and you know I can do it and I
can you know um but as time's gone on
you know I'm lucky to have an older
brother I would say he's definitely like
knocked a lot of ideas out of me I guess
you know like maybe see things in a
leadership baby yeah so now I would say
you know like I have like this trained
mindset so I feel like my brother's like
prepared me for the right man but so but
I'm curious is there something which men
prefer a woman who he doesn't need to
train like of course she needs to be
trained to his liking right and how he
likes everything to go how you know he
likes the food you know my future
husband isn't gonna like his chicken
season the way my brother it's chicken
season you know it's all different but
I'm saying is that more valued over a
woman who doesn't know anything and then
you've got to like take all this time to
just like train her and teach her and
you know debate with her and so you're
like in her fantastic position and I've
always said this too like you know very
positive yeah yeah I mean I I really do
love the relationship that you have with
your brother and that's that's great I
wish more women had it because if more
women had it they would be better
girlfriends and or wives in the future
and the thing is is that I've said this
before and I'll say it again the best
person to advise a woman is her brother
her father her uncle men that don't have
a sexual interest in her why because
they're going to give her the real deal
hey this is what you need to do this is
how you be attractive Etc and they can
give you truly objective advice that's
going to make you the best counterpart
for a man of value right because they
don't have a sexual interestingness
they're going to keep it a thousand
right so that's one thing I think that
need that's something that I wish stood
more about you know we have fathers
households broken families it's
something that's rare which is why I
really uh admire this this relationship
that you have with your brother but um I
would say if they don't have that
I would say trainable is good and the
reason why I tell guys is you need to be
able to train your girls because
unfortunately a lot of women don't have
you know a strong brother a father Etc
so you have to come in and you have to
be that leader and teach her how to be a
good girlfriend a lot of the times so it
used to be right like 56 years ago when
chivalry was a thing by the way you can
meet a girl and she came what I call
pre-assembled she came from a two-parent
household her father and her mother
instilled certain values in her she
understood what it was to be a lady you
didn't have to do too much work like an
average guy would could be rest assured
that he'd be able to get a woman and
she'd be a dutiful wife and she'd be a
good wife and she'd raise his children
and they'd be able to you know get the
white picket fence and you know the
family nuclear family dog two kids all
that but those days are done man women
aren't necessarily women anymore like
women are more masculinized now and you
have to almost train that out of them to
a degree right now I don't have a
problem with women that want to enter
the workforce and make money Etc my
issue is that when they prioritize that
over family and children because at the
end of the day the nuclear family is the
backbone of any thriving Society but
it's going down the hill and I know
people might say well Myron you're
contradicting because you teach girls
how to get laid blah blah blah blah and
here's here's my argument to that
I wish it was a 1950s I wish nuclear
families were a thing I wish two parent
households were a thing but my thing is
I don't make excuses and cry I give
Solutions you have to adapt to the
ever-changing marketplace so one of my
controversial takes is I tell guys for
you to be a good counterpart in today's
day and age you need to be making six
figures per year have six months of one
year savings be in shape uh be um
uh be 35 years old before you think of
marriage right because at that point you
have some wisdom in you and had sex with
50 girls and everyone looks at me
that's crazy 50 isn't really that much
in today's day and age I know girls that
do that in a semester in college
I know I know I know you don't but like
I'm telling you a lot of girls get
around like if you meet a girl that went
to a good University and she was a
center of sorority or she was involved
in sports or something bruh she's gonna
by the time she's out of there she's
gonna have at least 20 bodies at least
and here's the thing I always tell guys
this the reason why you need to have
these things in place as a man so your
brother agrees with me yeah I know he
agrees with everything and he said like
let me tell you
so
so this is the analogy right let's go
into a dream room real quick right let's
do it yeah so
imagine that you've got to get into a
ring right but you've never trained in
martial arts you never trained in any
you know mixed martial arts combat
you've never fought in your life you're
a [__] white belt okay
but in three days you gotta get in the
ring with someone that's a black belt
that's been training for 20 years
what's gonna happen when you get in that
ring I'm getting killed you're gonna get
[__] up right that is a Dynamics
between a man and a woman and I'll
explain that's true by the time a woman
hits puberty she's been hit on and
talked to by the opposite gender
thousands of times so she's become very
good at deflecting losers figuring out
who's a winner figuring out this guy's
confident this guy's a weirdo this guy
is a higher status guy this guy is yeah
I'm just going to finesse him for
whatever women become black belts in the
game of dating and dealing with the
opposite gender men on the other hand he
might not work up the courage to talk to
a girl and he's 22. so you have what 10
years behind a woman so you're gonna go
ahead at 35 years old no sexual
experience or worse yet mid-20s no
sexual experience no money no status no
um gym no competence no nothing and
you're going to go ahead and get in the
ring with a woman by the time she's 25
she's a black belt with dealing with the
opposite gender she's gonna finesse you
all over the place because she knows
what to tell you she knows how to
appease to Your Ego your dumbass oh my
God you're so good meanwhile you wore
three pumps and you [__] came like
women know how to get in a guy's head so
if a guy isn't aware and hasn't been
training in the gym right what worked up
to a black belt so he can at least
compete like he's gonna get finesse and
destroyed so that's what I always say
like the dating dynamic between a man
and a woman a lot of the time the woman
is a black belt beating the [__] out of
the guy but the guy doesn't even realize
until he walks into the divorce court
loses half his money he didn't realize
wow I got for moose because he didn't
have the sexual experience he didn't
have what I call the backlog the
Encyclopedia of dealing with a bunch of
women to figure out which girls are good
which girls are bad which girls are hoes
which girls are white material which
girls are worthy of dating seriously
which girls are not you got to be able
to figure all this [__] out you got to
be able to put women in boxes because
you women definitely put men in boxes
they meet this guy sugar daddy this guy
trick this guy okay I can actually date
him okay this guy loser this guy friend
zone like when we put dudes in boxes all
day but dudes first girl that [__]
says hello wife wife yeah woo [__]
idiot and then this guy might be worth a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
doesn't know any better gets finessed so
my thing is I tell guys go in the
[__] dojo and train you need to go
ahead and spoil with a bunch of people
and figure it out because by the time
you meet your girl your dream girl by
the time she's 21 she's a 10 degree
black belt bro she's deflecting losers
all over the place she knows how to do
that Aikido is you know Andrew would say
so guys got to get in the ring and train
man and guys don't want to [__] train
they want to wipe up the first girl that
comes to him and get [__] up so let's
get into more of this
no it's great I love it thank you for it
I love the energy that you bring it's
amazing
um so what then is the problem with
Modern Men because right now men are
running to people like Jordan Peterson
Andrew Tate you know you
um Elon musk even is becoming like this
this this guy this guy for men you know
he's got multiple children with multiple
different women yeah good for him you
know I'm happy for him um so why are men
so uh desperate to seek out some kind of
role model that just sets the standard
so you know it's interesting because I
get criticized all the time because they
say oh Myron all you do is Bash women
people need to watch the daytime show
because I go even harder on the guys the
reason why we're in this [__] up world
where women are masculine fat annoying
stupid crass Etc is because the men
can't put women in their place so it
starts with the men the men aren't
leaders so the women are going crazy
acting crazy and that's what it is and
the reason why is because guys are fat
they're not going to the gym they're not
training they're not learning a
discipline they're not
um they're just they're broke their bums
like there's no ambition they're smoking
[__] weed every day don't even get me
started on 420. while you losers over
there smoking pot on 420. I was doing
four sets towards 20 at 3am in the
[__] morning the problem is that guys
right have no real semblance of you must
accomplish things right
competence leaves accomplishments which
then leads to confidence guys stick I'm
gonna magically manufacture some
confidence somewhere no you're gonna get
Confidence from your competence and
accomplishments but guys don't
understand that it goes in a trajectory
that's how it goes you have to
accomplish something so that you have
the confidence so women actually respect
you the reason why women look at
confidence so much in a man is because
it's an honest indicator you've [__]
done something but the problem is that
so many guys haven't done [__] they're
smoking pot all day they're whacking off
to porn they're not being social they're
not getting out themselves out there and
putting themselves in uncomfortable
positions more guys need to learn how to
be comfortable being uncomfortable but
we live in this pussified [__]
society where we can't bully guys
anymore everyone's getting a
participation trophy people aren't
playing sports boys are [__] fat
they're not fighting anymore you need to
put guys in competition situations where
there's winners and [__] losers
because when you have losers winds up
happening it's like damn
I lost
I need to go reassess what I did train
harder so that I can come back and win
some of my best lessons came from what
and L there's no such thing as losses if
you're a man and actually on your
purpose it's just Lessons Learned but
the thing is is that we got
a bunch of so I'm just going to say it
soft mother
really soft it's pathetic it's really
pathetic when I see [__] like
um
I'll give an example I was watching this
video went viral this [__] bus driver
right the kids weren't listening that
right and they were like [__]
standing up and the bus driver's like
hey sit in your seats or else y'all are
going to get a lesson and then the kid's
like what does he do hits the [__]
breaks all the kids oh oh no [__] hit
their heads and [__] I was like yo they
used to do that [__] to us all the
[__] time guess what happens all the
[__] pussified parents so we need to
report this bus driver yeah we can't get
her blah blah blah no that's fantastic
it's a life
lesson follow instructions or get hurt
but we we can't do that [__] no more
kids are so [__] soft nowadays like
bullying oh my God cyber bullying bro I
wish these [__] are playing
Xbox live in 2004. yeah yo the crazy
[__] man out of man I'm not even gonna
say it but the crazy [__] that you would
hear when you got on Xbox Live that [__]
made you have thick skin right men grow
Stronger by bullying each other fighting
each other just it's what it's how you
earn your stripes but guys are learning
Stripes anymore
they're trying to call themselves a
tiger with no [__] sharks what the
hell's going on you must suffer as a man
if you don't suffer as a man you're not
going to learn how to overcome adversity
if you don't learn how to over learn how
to overcome adversity you're not going
to become anything that's why we got
that's why honestly
a lot of these YouTubers that critique
us and all this other [__] that talk
[__] I don't respect them they don't
have a real job they never did anything
they really never accomplished anything
so these [__] goes Larry dear [__]
loser what the [__] have you done you
know I thank God that I actually had a
real job did some real [__] before I
became a millionaire like if I had
become a millionaire like in my mid-20s
or some [__] haven't accomplished
anything I'd be a [__] [__] I'd be
soft oh yeah look at me I'm so cool blah
blah but no I did real [__] so and I
went through a lot of [__] adversity
right [__] arguing with FBI agents
over [__] case arguing with DHS
coming to blow sometimes over this is
our seizure no it's not blah blah blah
fighting will upper management to get
money from my cases to get funded
[__] fighting for overtime it's it
was a very difficult job you know
arresting some of the worst people
arresting pedophiles arresting corrupt
cops all the [__] I've done but it made
me a stronger man it made me grow up
immediately right in my 20s instead of
going out and partying and doing all the
[__] [__] I was like learning how to
become a man I think that's what guys
need to do enough God not enough guys
are going out there and suffering you
need to get out there better and [__]
suffering the easiest way to do that is
going to the gym it amazes me how many
young guys don't train
how the [__] are you expecting to get a
dick [__] to suck your dick when you
can't even lift your stomach what the
hell is going on here this is ridiculous
Cloud world but we sit here and say oh
no it's okay it's okay to be fat
Ridiculousness man I could rant about
this all day but no it's it's I know
y'all only got amount of films no it's
true it's funny I'm just trying to like
figure out where like how much personal
information to give her um I mean I like
just like I don't know I mean I had a
that was a guy that wanted to date me
and he was actually quite fat and I was
just like I was almost like offended I'm
like I'm in the gym four times a week
yeah and like you you like you want to
like marry me and I'm and like go
overweight what you know I'm just like
I'm like just just lose some weight like
I don't understand I'm in the gym four
times a week yeah you know when you're
fat you quite effectively don't respect
yourself right so how can I respect you
if you yeah no exactly and it's very
simple it's not that difficult and I was
asking you to go out and kill a bear and
bring it home you know it's easier today
um and if you're fat also it shows that
you lack discipline which is a
Cornerstone of success as a man if you
can't even control what the [__] goes in
your mouth how the hell are you gonna
control anything else the one thing you
can control is your Fitness and your
weight you can't control that what the
[__] is going on how are you going to
control all the bad dangerous things
that could potentially happen to me as
your woman if you can't control you
can't ever Chase somebody down exactly
incredible yeah exactly and you know
like uh going back to how it is in
schools with participation trophies and
everything I don't know what it is like
in the States but in England
um teachers aren't allowed to write in
red anymore because that scares the kids
so you know how like they would do like
tick cross and all this stuff with on
your work give you feedback in red now
it has to be in purple
wow yeah my mom's a teacher so she was
telling me yo yeah failed Society I've
said this so many times like we bring
girls on the Pod and they're we need to
go back to telling people that they're
stupid because here's the thing we need
to stop positively reinforcing stupidity
oh no
no opinion is valid your opinion is
about whatever happened to telling
people their opinion is [__] wrong
you're stupid one plus one is two the
sky is blue I don't give a [__] about
your feelings you're dumb change the way
that you think we need to stop
validifying stupidity that's true you
like stop like I don't know what is
going on here like we live in this crazy
world right where we think
that everyone's opinion right is valid
and should be heard but here's the thing
people right have different life
experiences there are different points
in their life and unfortunately
people right A lot of times give their
opinion based off how they feel no you
got to go off of what's real and what's
objective this whole my true thing
anytime someone says my truth I'm like
low IQ there's just one truth
there's no my truth it's the truth
that's how it goes one [__] truth man
but everyone thinks my truth matters my
truth matters no you're just a [__]
[__] that's how you feel and that's not
necessarily what's real but it's crazy
to me like that we sit here and we
literally let morons talk about how they
feel like it matters it doesn't [__]
matter you're an idiot get the [__] out
of here you're a [__] you don't see the
world for what it really is my feelings
everyone should get a voice no everyone
shouldn't get a voice because there's a
lot of idiots you know like the average
person's IQ is like what like 80 or some
[__] like that 80 90. [__] morons
everywhere like the more I in uh you
know the more I talk with people and
everything else like that I just realize
like people are so [__] stupid in
general like people lack it's not just
women too it's everyone men women a lot
of these lip tards on the left they lack
critical thinking skills they really do
whoa there's 97 genders oh that's
problematic like what the [__] is going
on calling their hair blue and [__] like
that fat as [__] looking like [__]
talking [__] about us losers like H3 and
lassan fagabi like incredible incredible
and these guys have big platforms and
they're indoctrinating a bunch of
[__] [__] to think about their
feelings and how oh my God this is the
way it should be bruh there's certain
things that are just a fact regardless
of how you feel anyway yeah no I think
it's brilliant I love this energy and I
love everything that you guys talk about
you know making men men again women like
me we need this we admire this that's
why I need leadership like like guys are
too [__] soft how the hell are you
gonna lead someone when you're
incompetent you're fat Etc like like and
I always say right like if you look at
the battlefield right
if you're like out in war and you're you
know you're fighting the enemy Etc and
your [__] Lieutenant comes in like oh
my God I don't know what we're gonna do
oh my God like do you think your
soldiers are gonna [__] follow you no
they're gonna be like what the [__] is
going on they're gonna go off their own
and quite effectively that's what's
happening in relationships the guys are
incompetent the girls at the girl has to
[__] come in and take leadership Etc
and guys wonder why women don't respect
them when guys wonder why they can't get
sex out of their girl guys wonder why
she's out here talking to her co-workers
they wonder why she's why does she need
all this attention it's because you're a
[__] she doesn't respect you does she
doesn't like you she's just tolerating
you you're a placeholder boyfriend okay
so let's change gears a little bit sure
um okay so what can a woman do to retain
a man and before you answer sure I also
want to understand what can a woman do
to make herself available to him so she
knows that so he knows that she's
interested but then not coming across as
like too crazy because obviously a man
from what I've learned from my brother
I've understood that a man wants to know
that that she's about him yeah like I'm
for you you're the man I want you right
that's apparently how it needs to go so
but then isn't can't she come on too
strong like what could a woman do
so
do you want me to speak for me or
objectively like for men in general
wouldn't it be the same
no because I I've learned some things
that I've had to kind of uh learn from
like my experience for example I'd like
to give an example so right it used to
be if a girl bothered me a lot and
texted me a lot I would get annoyed and
frustrated like what the [__] but then I
realized oh this girl's not a [__] she's
actually invested and she doesn't do
this all the time which is why she's
annoying the [__] out of me because she
feels a sense of connection because
she's like okay I'll hook up with anyone
so bam immediately she she's like
bonding to me right so I'm like okay
cool right so I'm like I used to get
annoyed by that but then I was like no
that's actually a good sign so I've come
to respect that and um
tolerate it more where it used to annoy
me right
um but I would say is like for a girl in
general right so like that's my thing
right I got annoyed but it took me some
time to figure it out right so that's
some personal reflection but for a woman
in general right obviously don't be
annoying about it but what I would say
is like you got to come in and figure
out where the guy is deficient and then
kind of come in and fill that void and
when women are and here's the thing too
like women are fantastic at like being
socially aware socially calibrated
seeing things they can walk into a room
and read the room like women need to
take that skill set and be able to
figure out what their guy needs right so
like
if you go into his place and you realize
okay this guy probably needs some
[__] spoons or some [__] like that
this guy you know most guys are bachelor
pad guys and they don't have [__] maybe
one spoon one for it bring in like a so
a silver set or something like that
right yeah bring some spoons and forks
like wow he's really gonna appreciate
that because dude I can't tell you how
many guys go through life and they've
never received anything from a woman
ever besides their mom so a girl being
like um creative and thoughtful like
that goes a mile like like really far
because most girls don't give guys [__]
but what if it's early and like you
don't know I'm asking for personal I
don't know
where like where the Gap is in his life
and you just you see him you're like
okay that that's a cool one I like him
yeah I think I think uh women are too
scared of um showing interest and
they're too scared of investing early on
because women are like typically aren't
used investing but what I would say is
if the guy's a winner you got to kind of
set it start you know stand out from the
other girls and investing in a guy early
on
it's a risk it's always a risk right
because you don't know where that man
stands he might want to just [__]
[__] and he might not even want a
serious girlfriend or you might have to
do here's another thing that's unpopular
but I tell girls all the time you might
have to play the waiting game and what I
mean by this is
understand like let's say he's not
willing to commit but you really like
him you're just always there you're
always available you're the one that
pretty much rides it out you're the one
that writes it I can't tell you how many
times where one of my main chicks like
she just wrote it out longer than the
other girls and provided more value over
a longer period of time I was like God
damn okay and then she starts to get
Privileges and certain accesses to other
girls aren't and then just by virtue of
her being around to being available
being useful being an asset I can't kick
her to the curb because she's too
goddamn useful and what will end up
happening and I've always said like when
a woman is like coachable and trainable
that man will train her to into a woman
that he will grow to eventually love
that's why the guy's got to be
leadership role when a woman changes a
man she's going to change him into
something she's eventually going to hate
and resent because he was able to change
right but when a man is able to change
or grow into what he needs he's going to
grow to love her because she's like damn
I can't operate with that scroll like
bro I don't even know how to do my
laundry or nothing like like once a
woman becomes an indispensable piece of
that man's repertoire you [__] got
him but that takes time that takes him
investment that takes risking that takes
also the the ability to be like okay
he's he might [__] other [__] he's not
ready right now but I'm gonna stand the
test of time and at the end of the day
all these other hoes are going to come
in and out I'm gonna be here I'm gonna
be for him and then trust me they're
gonna notice that because the thing
about modern day women is this
women have so many options nowadays that
they're not patient so since they have
so many options they're like why am I
going to wait on this guy I got this MLB
player talking to me I got this NBA
player over here I got this NFL player
so since women have all these options
what ends up happening is they conflate
those options with real
um relationship opportunities and the
two are not the same just because you
can [__] this guy doesn't mean you can
retain this guy so if you do find the
guy that you like you think he's worth
it Etc it's on the girl too to have some
critical thinking skills and figure out
the guy's worth it but I can't tell you
how many times just playing the long
game and being there and Lasting all
outlasting all the other girls and
adding value bruh he has no choice but
to pick you and even if you don't even
if you don't get like picked as like the
main main girl you're gonna still be one
of the girls
that's loyalty and that's very very
difficult to find with the way women are
because women are taught to trade out
women are taught to find another guy
women are taught to date and exercise
options Etc if you go against the grain
and you actually stay loyal to that guy
over the long period of time and you and
the big thing is outlasting the other
girls man that's going to leave a crazy
impression so just adding as much value
as possible just always being there yeah
and just I can't tell you how many times
like girls that are like not even the
hottest of the hot they just outlasted
other hot girls because I've always said
that hot girls are useless because
they've rarely had to be useful in their
life so even if you're a girl that's
like maybe six seven whatever
you're going to outlast the bad [__]
because bad [__] are useless yeah so
difficult
it's competitive and this is the thing
this is the thing with for women that
they don't understand the problem is
that there's not enough eligible
bachelors to go around exactly so for
women it really sucks because the more
successful you are the prettier you are
the more money you have Etc you're
competing for a very small pool of men
so the way you're gonna win a lot of
times is just Outlet outlasting to other
girls this is literally my brother tells
me like my brother will tell me like no
you should speak to this guy and I'm
like no I shouldn't and you know and
he's like no no Leia you should you
should and I'm like all right I'll do it
because you tell me to yeah higher
status men a lot of the times aren't
going to chase women yeah that's that's
another thing too that kind of women
need to understand is that like once you
get with a guy that has options Etc you
you're gonna have to do a good amount of
the pursuing interesting and and it
might be for a period of time but you'll
start to notice that you're like getting
a more serious position he's like hey
I'm gonna go do this you want to come
with me you want to travel with me or he
starts inviting you into a more personal
things introduces you to his friends or
whatever maybe these are all like good
signs that you're like moving up the
totem pole fascinating it's really
really interesting okay let's keep this
going get other girls oh [__] have you
got other girls I can't do that I can't
do that but that would really say yeah
you'd be like God damn because most
girls the more things that you could do
that other women aren't willing to do
get all the get all the women oh I know
I could do that one it was tough I don't
know hey let me let me enable your
cheating on me let me enable this I
don't know if I can I'd much rather add
even more value in a different way so
that he's like I don't want to lose that
by cheating on her yeah
I mean like for the higher status guy if
you're able to do that again I'm giving
you the game and the cheat codes to beat
out other girls because most girls are
not willing to do that yeah no I
appreciate that thanks Myron yeah um so
I'm really curious how do you have such
a great understanding of men and women
you know what are you like 30 33 33 yeah
that's pretty young how do you so it's a
unique situation right so when I was an
agent I had informants that were both
women and men I had suspects that I
talked to that were both women and men
and I realized that you have to talk to
the two genders differently right
um so that was kind of like the the
basis like right when you're trying to
get information from people you really
need to understand them especially when
you're getting information from them
that's like can put them in jail for the
rest of their life so you have to figure
out how to talk to those who genders and
talk to them differently and then
um doing the podcast right and then men
I just have a obviously I'm a guy so men
are very simple like we all are you yeah
we are dude look at your brothers but
nodding with everything I say we agree
on most the things it's just that the
things that men can't really be vocal
about the things that they want to say
that's why people love Andrew so much
because he's very candid and upfront
about what men really want and how they
feel about things and Society honestly
can't handle it which is why he went
viral because these are conversations
that men have in private and locker
rooms Etc and women can handle the truth
in general that's why there was an
outrage and uh you know it is what is
but a lot of men think this way the only
difference between me and Andrew and
everybody else is that we just have the
balls to say it out in public for fear
of getting canceled or losing our jobs
or whatever in my case losing you know
getting being put in a position where
it's like resign or you know leave
whatever well sorry you got to leave
YouTube or you got to resign one of the
two whatever [__] but either way
um just operating on caffeine now no
sleep uh but going back to the original
thing yeah how did you learn so much
about mail yes I've interviewed now well
over 2 000 women on the show from
different walks of life so that's
created like a whole you know backlog of
like
how women think and I've just noticed
very similar
um
things between different women
regardless of income level education
whatever and all I've noticed that when
a woman is more educated makes more
money she just tends to be more vocal
and more articulate about what she wants
out of her partner and less like less
likely to settle the more education the
more money she makes the the more likely
there to be they'll say I'd rather be
single than be with a loser because if
you think about it the whole a big
reason why women chase a career and
making money Etc what do they say when
they make money I'm independent ask
yourself independent of who men when men
make money we don't say we're
independent they look at you like what
you [__] gay what's wrong with you
bro like no like men make money so that
a family can be dependent upon them
women make money to be independent of
the men they don't want so
my thing is is that uh when women make
their own money they're just even more
ten toes down on their standards of what
they want because that's the reason they
want to get the education in the first
place to set themselves apart and in
their head get a higher value man
because they think back to what I said
attraction is symmetrical I make 100 000
per year now I can get a guy that makes
100 000 but they don't realize they're
actually shooting themselves in the foot
doing that yeah
so just through interviewing
interviewing my prior experience with
you know talking to you know bad guys
that are both women and men in for
dealing with informants that was really
uh telling on how you need to talk to
the true denders when I had female
informants versus male informants
um so all these things helped a lot and
I've talked with like so many different
types of people from all different walks
of life and I'll never forget this one
interview uh when I was an agent it was
like a random Sunday I was on call and
um I get a call
and they're like uh at the border patrol
station right because on the Southwest
border there's border patrol border
patrol stations everywhere and they're
always catching legal aliens trying to
enter the country whatever so I was like
why the [__] are they calling me so they
call me and they're like hey there's
this guy who wants to provide
information and he has information at
the time I was I was in Laredo Texas
which across the border was Los Zetas
that ran it this is back in like 2015
2016. now I think it's cartel donoreste
but I'm out of the game now okay but
anyway so I'm like you know what I'll
talk to the guy because I was always I
was very hungry I was like I'll get more
informants at the time I was controlling
like six or seven informants informants
is how you make cases so I go over there
talk with the guy
and you know identify myself Etc it's
like I don't want to talk to any border
patrol agents I'll talk to a special
agent Boulevard because he knows that
they're the investigators Etc and they
can actually make [__] happen so I'm
talking with him and he's like okay so
this is what I do I am a a sicario I
basically write my American terms you
use it in Spanish but
um and his job he was protecting I think
it was z42 uh one at one of the Trevino
Brothers right
um at the time and they're the ones that
ran the Los Zetas back then and his job
right because there was a war going on
between the losettes and the Mexican
Marines right and that's the military
like they're beyond police now that's
how bad the corruption is so they're
fighting Armored Cars machine guns all
this crap so this guy's job was anytime
they were driving in their motorcade and
the Mexican Marines would attack them
his job was to create a diversion to lay
some cover fire and then let the boss
get away and then he got paid a bonus
for every single Mexican Marine he
killed and what he did was he would cut
a body part off and bring it back to the
boss so that he can say these are the
people I killed and he would pay him a
bonus for each Body Party brought
because I was a body uh that meant for
someone he killed that's how much they
had to the Mexican and the way he talked
about it so can did a matter of fact or
whatever it was like bone chilling right
but I was able to get that information
from being like you know just kind of
playing off of him right not being
judgmental you know we call it uh kind
of like you don't want I don't want to
say empathizing but you're kind of
minimizing you're you yeah you have to
befriend them that's a big part of it
and then you minimize their situation oh
well it's not like you're touching kids
right it's like you you know you can
only go so low right but it's like yeah
I get it you know you had to make this
happen right you got to protect your
family you got to feed your family Etc
so it's kind of a sick tactic but that's
what you have to do to empathize with
these Crooks and get the most
information so little tactics like that
is what I learned because like you know
when you're talking with the worst the
worst to delusional women it makes it
way easier yeah I love the comparison
yeah it's crazy dude all the different
spectrums yeah very well versed one
video actually of yours popped up
recently um and it blew my mind
um and I thought I've never heard this
before you're the first person who's
ever brought this to likes I feel like
I'm pretty like based or well-read and
all sorts of things but this one I've
never heard of
um you were basically talking about
mummy's boys and how in the west if a
man is close with his mother yeah he's
considered a loser and a mummy's boy um
and then you then went on to explain the
reason why this is so let's get into
this I absolutely loved what you said so
explain why is being a mummy's boy
actually a good thing or like why are
they attacking the relationship between
a man and his mother so going back to
what I said before remember how I said
uh when you're you know doing the karate
and everything else like that and you're
a black belt if you're a Mommy's boy
you're automatically elevated to blue
belt and the reason why is because your
mom right is an insulation in her first
line of defense when you deal with
problematic women if she's a good mom
yeah she you know you bring in a chick
that's you know a leech right she's not
really adding too much value Etc your
mom will meet that woman be like no I'm
good especially if her son is a higher
earner he has a lot to lose Etc your mom
is going to kind of come in and like be
a vulture on that chick this is why so
many women hate mommy's boys because
your the mom a lot of the times is going
to defend the son from vultures women
because women understand women better
than anybody else and that's why I say
women don't get along with each other
because they understand each other
um so the reason why in the west they
hate that is because when you live in
pro-feminist countries where divorce
highly favors women Etc the mom a lot of
times gets in the way of the woman being
able to extract the resources from the
Sun through marriage and divorce court
and the state that's why they hate us so
much but if you go to like other
countries where you know gender roles
are traditional Etc it's not that big of
a deal for a man to be a mama's boy
because the mom so excuse me the woman
she's a daddy's girl right just like I
said before the brother and the dad a
lot of times protect the daughter from
[__] from the men same thing with the
sister and the mom if they come from a
good family they should be doing the
same thing this chick ain't good for you
what the [__] are you doing she's a
[__] I know she is you know or she just
wants you for your money whatever she's
able to like Snap the guy out of reality
a bit because a lot of times the guy's
just like should you touch my pee pee
let's do it you know so the mom or the
sister if they're good sibling they kind
of come in or a good mother first line
of defense same thing with and that's
what families should do they should
protect their siblings from the opposite
General a lot of times because when your
sibling or your mom or your father comes
in there's no sexual interest so they're
able to give you a objective good advice
from the other party
I think I mean my brother's in his late
20s but I think when he gets to marriage
age so like 35 I think I'll be 100
probably terrible any woman that comes
that comes in I'll be like don't like
that one don't like that one that's the
way it's got to be worth it yeah yeah
that's the way it's got to be and I
think this is why family is so important
because if a family does his job
correctly right they're very protective
of who comes in because they're looking
at it like you're not going to come in
and [__] up what we created you so um a
Mommy's boy a lot of times that Mom is
the first line of defense which is why
she's so hated in the west because she
is the first line of defense from the
divorce courts destroying her son if
she's a good mom yeah and it's true
because if a girlfriend said to me oh
don't go for him he's a Mommy's boy you
would naturally just be put off wouldn't
you yeah well wouldn't we yeah we'd be
put off so that's when you said that I
was like oh wow yeah and that actually
makes sense because at the same time I
wouldn't want to marry a man who has a
bad relationship with his mother like
that would be a red flag so if we don't
want a man who has a bad relationship
with his mother yet we don't yet we
don't want a man that's a Mommy's boy
what are we what are we doing well it
comes back to the contradictory nature
of like what we want in the West in
general right they want a gentleman but
they they want a guy that like can do
token and bang them like crazy right
like you know that you call um like the
uh 50 Shades of Gray right uh Christian
Gray they want that guy right but at the
same time they want a chivalrous nice
guy and and it's really the guy has to
again coming back to the the men right
it's on the burning performance is on us
you have to have a combination of the
two but a lot of the times what women
want is contradictory to what they're
aroused by they'll say I want this but
the reality is what they're aroused by
are two different things yeah and that's
something which I think your content
does really well and it's something that
I'm learning because I saw a video the
other day saying um women never go for
the men they want they always go for the
safe option so now I'm like I'm not
going for the safe option I'm gonna get
the man I want that's what I'm gonna
like that's yeah yeah so it's really
interesting yeah I mean I I tell girls
like go for the man that you want when
you step the sexual market value to
command that man that you want because
that's you know unfortunately for women
right you only have a finite amount of
time to get the guy that you want a
woman's sexual market value
unfortunately is perishable now here's
the thing right it's it's it's so
I always say so like with women right
when you're at your Peak you burn bright
and strong no one can stop you like
literally like uh it's like
um
you know I talked about uh I love Tate's
analogy on this where he talks about the
um the queen on the chessboard right you
can move as many spaces you want one of
the most powerful pieces on the board
but here's the problem
you can die and the game will still
continue and on top of that I can get a
pawn to the other side and turn her into
a queen so it's on women to understand
that you have this power for a finite
amount of time get the guy when you have
that power before another Pawn replaces
you
yeah it's a hard difficult word out
there it's a hard work it's hard for men
as well and it's tough and they've done
this like it's literally like um they
did study like um when you have like an
ice cream shop I think it was if I'm not
mistaken like when you have four flavors
people are far more likely to pick a
flavor that they want versus when you
have 20 30 flavors it's very difficult
they don't make a they don't make a
selection they don't buy and then they
leave I think that's kind of where women
are right now with the dating game so
many options so many guys hitting them
up Etc it's very difficult to decipher
and I do again empathize with women
because I understand the female struggle
right I've seen plenty of women's DMS
I've seen it from the other perspective
like women are bombarded with choice so
it's really difficult when all these
high status guys are hitting you up
because this is what men keep getting
wrong but I've seen it all the time men
are going on about how like oh you have
so much choice you haven't like but like
they're losers yes like they're not like
not good choice like it's not as if
they're like all these high value men
that are just ready to marry you a lot
of them are just losers offering dick
and even the higher status guys they're
just offering dicks so it's really
difficult for women to like figure out
which guy's gonna take me seriously
right because the guy that is attractive
that's arousing a lot of times is bad
boy is he gonna commit and then the guy
that's super nice oh give me some
flowers he's [__] boring you don't
want to be with him so it's it's a very
difficult situation but I would say if
you find if if you're attractive you've
got the sexual market value go for the
guy that you want
Outlast the other chicks yeah at least
you'll be happy with that guy that's
true if it does work out and if you take
a l that's the risk of being a female
men have to take risks too but men have
to take risk women have to take risk as
well yeah you know absolutely I'm
curious do you think that the red pill
content can ever go too far so I ask
because it's pretty wild on the internet
right now um and I I keep seeing um like
really ugly 50 year old men celebrating
when um a woman shows um signs of aging
and it's and it's like haha Emma Watson
she's aging and it's like this ugly 50
year old broke man and it's like and
then and then everyone like celebrates
and then like it's like do you know I
thought you've got a bit too far like we
all age you know yeah can we not just
get on and be friends
which point
you're good it's fine which point now I
know oh no because that's a different
point no because environ's gonna be like
okay okay I'll say it
they can't hear you they can't hear you
okay I'll make the point okay yeah right
so there's a man that I saw on Twitter
yeah that was basically I'm laughing at
Emma Watson because she's showing signs
of aging oh my God she hit 31 or 30.
what terrible so um but the crazy thing
is as my brother was just alluding to
um that Emma Watson is more successful
and has more money than this man who's
completely broke and all he can do is
just be fat and ugly be alone and then
laugh at a woman for aging so so can
does a red pill content go too far like
at what point are you an inside on a
loser yeah um yeah so I I've always said
right so so here's the thing so I always
look at like the manosphere in general
like we're all using the same tool right
we all are using RP awareness right
which is understanding female nature and
adapting to it now everyone has a
different strategy some guys understand
in nature and teach guys how to adapt to
it in the modern day dating Place hey a
dating Marketplace you got to become the
best man and let the women be a
byproduct some guys say I'm gonna go on
my own and go Midtown say I'm not gonna
deal women at all some guys are black
pilling like oh my God life sucks blah
blah blah but we all are using the same
tool which is red RP awareness which is
the same thing I would say you know
what's the similarity between a serial
killer a culinary chef and your mom well
they all use a knife to make food right
well they all use a knife some people
are doing it to make Exquisite meals
other people are doing it to slice you
up but they're all using the same tool
for different purposes so my thing is I
tell guys
my if you want to go ahead and leave the
marketplace and not deal women cool but
I want you to make that decision not
women make that decision for you if
you're going to go your own way you go
your own way don't sit there and cook
don't say and get sent your own way so
with these guys that are mad or whatever
a lot of the guys are mad because let's
be honest maybe they got rejected they
have tough time with dealing with women
and the way guys look at it is this
right so and I'll give you kind of the
perspective I don't necessarily agree
with like laughing at chicks that are
getting old but the reason why guys
laugh at it is because I always say that
women quite effectively are trust fund
babies men are self-made millionaires so
whenever you see a trust fund baby you
know blow all their money on coke and
hookers in Vegas and become a bum you
laugh because you're like what the [__]
you had the opportunity of a lifetime
and you blew it that's how a lot of
women have it right all women basically
are trustful babies and can use their
money and invest it properly and become
a multi-multi-millionaire men on the
other hand they have to become that
multi-millionaire and there's a slim
chance of that being honest let's be
honest our guy's going to be a top one
percent no but that's what women are
chasing so that's why so many guys get a
gratification out of it because they're
like [__] you have the world and you
[__] up now is that the correct way to
adapt to it probably not you know
laughing at old chicks is like you know
that gets old but no pun intended but
you know it is what it is yeah I know I
appreciate you explaining that yeah um
so you are very vocal on the internet
and your um your content gets extremely
Rowdy and I know you have kicked women
off many different times have you ever
been demonetized or have you ever been
um afraid that any of your content will
be taken down yeah I mean uh definitely
we've you know with the type of content
that we make I already know it's
volatile people are always good I've
been banned off Tick Tock and you know
videos have been taken down Etc uh you
know we just got out of YouTube jail we
had a strike or whatever so yeah this
type of content I foresee like in the
next
year or two anything that's like Pro
masculine content anything that's
conservative or whatever it's probably
going to get flagged or whatever you
can't be honest nowadays it's crazy man
which is why Rumble is like blowing up
if you look I mean hell they even got
crazy liberals on there as well so even
on Rumble but it's mostly conservatives
right you got your you know your Stephen
Crowders Trump son is over there
um you know a lot of great content
creators over there but I think rumble's
going to be the future honestly with all
this stuff going on with YouTube yeah I
definitely think um new alternative
platforms will be the future my only
concern and you can give me your take on
this is um centralized platforms when
there's like a CEO and things like that
since my native interest is crypto yeah
I'm more driven to things which are
decentralized of course so something
like so I don't know if you have you
heard of Tommy net no I never have so
Tommy net are building a new
decentralized internet um it's like a
it's a whole infrastructure so they have
like a privacy coin they have a VPN they
have an internet they have a Content
platform like a whole thing yeah so I'm
so driven towards something like that
which is more decentralized what do you
think do you ever feel concerned that
there could be like a falling out with a
CEO or perhaps like everybody has a
price and you suddenly feel that
centralized I might have to move to
something more decentralized yeah um so
we we know the president of Rumble
personally and he's real big on Free
Speech I mean hell he's lost
um pretty much access in certain
countries for wanting to protect their
free speech so they're pretty serious
about it
um so I I do see Rumble as the future
um for you know any concert Critters
that like kind of Veer on the edge of
you know being provocative or
controversial
um but yeah man I mean that's kind of
how we've hedged against obviously I
invest in real estate heavily right you
know we can get we always make jokes on
the top of our show when we talk about
Rumble like hey we can get a castle
anytime so it is what it is so like I
think this is you know people got to be
smart invest in assets that pay them
back you know thankfully I'm in a
position now where if I got canceled I'd
be fine I'd be doing and I'm a
minimalist anyway so no matter but
um my thing is like it's not necessarily
about like making the most money
possible I really want to be able to you
know get as many guys in the gym being
attractive not being [__] losers
whatever because at the end of the day
man like you know money is great and all
but it's like it's not everything yeah
so especially in me where it's like I'm
not a the nicest thing I have is this AP
and I only bought it because it holds
value it looks really nice by the way I
didn't know I don't know about watching
I appreciate it but yeah like when it
comes to anything nice that I have like
if I'm gonna buy something it better
hold value or appreciate over time like
that's my biggest thing that's why like
you know I don't Diamond it on or doing
a stupid [__] bust it down you know so
but yeah I'm trying to get into
different asset classes I got real
estate precious metals uh cryptocurrency
obviously you better be getting into
Bitcoin oh yeah yeah I got a couple
Bitcoin a couple that's two what are you
talking about well a little bit more
than three more than two more than two
uh quite a got a good amount of ethereum
um but yeah I'm definitely gonna um I'm
gonna be buying right now because
ethereum is a little bit low it's around
1800 as at the time we're recording this
so definitely gonna buy some more
ethereum and where can people like you
get in touch with you or follow you and
just find out everything that you're
doing yeah um plug Yourself YouTube
Fresh and fit you know Rumble Instagram
unplug fit Instagram fresh and fit we're
all over the place you'll probably see
us on you know some article getting
hated on by feminists it sounds about
right yeah
um but Myron I want thank you so much
and
um I also want to thank you for the tips
about how to secure a high value man I'm
going to take that with me and there you
go you see me maybe I'll be married yeah
I'll see you with the rings you'll see
me with a ring on the correct finger
just Outlast the hose man that's what
you got to do Outlast the hose you got
this yeah thanks
guys make sure you check out fresh and
fit they're brilliant I think for men
and for women um I actually love the
content so thank you so much for coming
on thank you for having me thanks so
much for watching if you did enjoy this
content then please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe as we'll
be bringing you a lot more of it we'll
see you next week peace